mining is one of the most dangerous
professions in the world and while
advances in technology and safety
protocols have certainly eased the load
that these hardened laborers endure it
still remains a daring backbreaking
endeavor where accidents do happen and
your safety is never 100 percent
guaranteed but mining is also a less
common profession in the united states
today with mines incorporating more
technology and less overall manual labor
but it wasn't always that way in the
19th and early 20th centuries mining
companies employed hundreds of thousands
of workers across the country before
large machinery could mine surface pits
and maneuver large-scale explosives from
a safe distance mining was done manually
performed by teams of thousands of
workers tirelessly slaving in the dark
digging for precious resources such as
coal or limestone all while being
underpaid overworked and continually
endangered on the job mines were
operated by mining companies who often
took a large cut of a miner's paycheck a
1902 account of a coal miner's paycheck
claimed a 1.60 daily salary for a
10-hour shift even when adjusted for
inflation today that only comes out to
4.50 cents an hour which is below the
united states minimum wage and some of
that money would be taxed or given to
the company for providing housing for
the miners families in company towns
located adjacent to the mines while some
companies were better than others in
terms of safety unionizing and demanding
better pay or conditions was frowned
upon and there was always the risk of
being kicked out of the town by the
company if you were caught attempting to
do so because of the demand and cost of
living boys as young as age 9 worked in
mine shafts in grueling conditions this
treatment was a driving force in
necessitating child labor laws and worst
of all accidents in the mines were all
too common in the early 20th century
mining involves the usage of explosives
to carve out new sections of rock to
mine and if something went wrong it
could have resulted in a cave-in the
complete collapse of a mining tunnel or
the surrounding rock where dozens or
potentially even hundreds of miners
could be injured or worse you had to
work in complete darkness save for a few
well-placed torches push a cumulative
thousands of pounds of materials every
day and contend with the ever-present
risk of a gas leak which could suffocate
workers in a cramped narrow shaft or
even result in an explosion when coming
into contact with the materials used
during blasting in 1917 2692
coal mining deaths were recorded as a
result of various causes and that was
just one year of many the underground
has claimed countless lives as a result
of human greed prioritizing profits and
material output over safety it's an area
of nature we were never truly meant to
interact with and the sheer number of
things that can go wrong in a mining
operation proves that with all this
death danger and darkness it's no wonder
that the mining industry is the center
of a blood curdling anomaly that caught
the attention of the scp foundation
today on scp explained we'll be taking a
look at scp-2951
an anomaly given the elusive code name
of ten thousand years
it will as the channel's name implies
all be explained in due time the year is
1944. the lemon quarry a limestone mine
located near guthrie indiana is like
countless others in the country it's
owned by the bg hoadley mining group a
company that would soon find themselves
with one less mind to manage and a lot
of information to cover up and destroy
up until now the operation was
proceeding smoothly with the quarry's
limestone deposits providing rich beds
of materials to export and sell but all
that was about to change on august 23
1944 an earthquake occurred directly
underneath the lemon quarry seismic
activity in indiana is strange enough
due to the area's solid limestone
foundation and lack of fault lines but
it was about to get a whole lot stranger
naturally the company sent in an
exploratory team to assess the damage of
the structure fearing that the limestone
deposits were caved in or destroyed in
the process three hours later the team
returned to the surface reporting that
an important access tunnel had collapsed
entirely the tunnel was a necessary
section of the mine shaft and the
company supervisors couldn't afford to
lose it so a larger team of workers were
ordered to clear the debris from the
tunnel using their hands and as much
large machinery as they could fit into
the narrow shaft during this operation
another strange earthquake occurred
causing a tunnel to collapse behind the
crew clearing the access tunnel the
quarry was sent into a panic another
team was sent in to remove debris and
attempt to free the initial clearing
crew after four hours of tireless work
they were successful and the clearing
crew was saved but the original access
tunnel was still blocked this is when it
gets strange the crew also reported that
due to the earthquake shifting the
cavern a new tunnel one that hadn't been
cut by the mining group and was not
charted in the company's records was
opened during exploration of this newly
discovered tunnel it was described as
being smoothly cut and descending on a
slight decline the mining company
speculated that this may have been a
tunnel cut by a mining group prior to
the quarry's purchase by bg hoadley that
wasn't properly recorded they hoped it
would connect around to the primary
still blocked tunnel and so they
assembled another team of 23 men to use
the new passage to access the rear of
the blockage and determine whether or
not to use explosives to gain re-entry
into the block tunnel was viable and
this is where the details of the story
run short sometime afterwards there was
a third round of seismic activity this
time collapsing the mine's entrance
tunnel over the next three days teams
above ground removed rubble and debris
covering the entrance and the company's
supervisors attempted to contact the men
located underground using a telephone
cable line that ran into an access shaft
in the mine on the evening of the third
day an unknown individual emerged from
the secondary shaft and made it to the
surface what happened next is unknown
but due to their collection of
information regarding the lemon quarry
incident the foundation discovered a
single telegraph wired from the quarry
to the mining company's head offices in
louisville it read 26 8 1944. mine
abandoned tunnels remained collapsed 23
lost one of them came up the shaft we
tossed it back down wasn't right
sometime after this bg hoadley sold the
quarry where it's at abandoned for
decades and the events that occurred
there remaining hidden and forgotten
until june 4th 1998 when low seismic
activity was detected outside of
foundation facility site 81 foundation
geologists were dispatched to assess the
situation but were unable to determine
much information including where the
activity was coming from two weeks later
a missing person report was filed with
local law enforcement where a year old
boy disappeared after he and his friends
were trespassing in the lemon quarry
while search efforts were conducted the
boy remained missing but during those
searches of the quarry it was discovered
that there was an unsealed shaft located
beneath the mines above ground
maintenance building that led directly
into the mine itself a rescue team was
lowered into the shaft after all it was
possible that the boy could have fell in
and was still down there but due to the
unexpected death and length of the
access tunnel the team had to wait until
longer ropes and safety harnesses were
available the estimated depth of the
tunnel was 120 meters but the rescue
team reassessed those numbers after
exploring the shaft finding them to be
closer to 240 meters still the boy was
unable to be found and the rescue crews
reported feeling agitated as well as
having doubts about the perception of
the mine around them the five-man rescue
crew reported there being seven or eight
members of the team and one of the men
reported that they were in the mine to
look for gold and not the missing boy
after 43 minutes the team went radio
silent and ceased responding to
communications above ground the teams
retracted their tether but found that
more was being retracted than had gone
down the shaft after retracting 400
meters of tether the winch was
overwhelmed and came to a stop it was
these events that alerted the scp
foundation about potential anomalous
activity in the lemon quarry the
foundation took control of the rescue
efforts posing as a federal search and
rescue team they were successful
somewhat retrieving two of the five men
who were still connected to their
tethers but less connected to their
minds one man became violent when he
reached the surface and began to
physically attack foundation personnel
believing he was still deep within the
mind the other man was originally
believed to be comatose but after 20
minutes of unconsciousness he began
speaking unintelligibly in a voice that
wasn't his own but one of the other two
men he went down into the shaft with the
three other men did not surface two of
their tethers returned with the ropes
clean cut on their side the third was
clearly sliced with jagged pieces of
rock and covered in human blood across a
significant portion of its length after
the two men were transported to site-81
the foundation quickly administered
amnestics to all non-foundation
personnel and developed a new cover
story for the events that occurred the
lemon quarry was classified as scp-2950
for the interior of the mine being
subject to a regular spatial and
temporal anomalies a historical probe
into the bg hoadley company and the 1944
incident was launched and inside
scp-2951 the foundation dispatched four
members of the mobile task force trotter
5 a squad named hell's heroes to further
analyze what was occurring in the
underground the team entered the mine
through the secondary access shaft and
was ordered to spend no longer than 40
minutes in the mine there was though it
remained unlikely the slight chance that
they could recover the three lost search
and rescue members and the missing boy
though the foundation wasn't holding
their breath knowing very well how
strange mysterious and dangerous
anomalous locations can be the task
force descended and after a quick mic
check to determine that their recording
equipment was working they moved further
down the shaft it was dark and
unnaturally d after reaching 120 meters
they came to a stop an area where they
could walk around this contradicted the
240 meter depth reported by the rescue
team the task force looked for tether
hooks or any other physical evidence
from the original team but they only
found footprints moving around the dark
winding area they began to explore it
wasn't long before the operatives became
disoriented keeping in mind their
40-minute limit one operative started
the clock and the captain ordered him to
let him know whenever 10 minutes had
passed while exploring they noticed two
tether lines up against a wall of rock
they took pictures and moved on
descending beeper the time-keeping
soldier reported that they clocked in 10
minutes but the others felt like it had
been longer than that coming to a narrow
tight access shaft the team determined
that they needed to move single file
while significant time was passing the
timekeeper only reported that they had
been underground for 17 minutes being
skilled in anomalous exploration the
team members realized that there was
something wrong and that this was most
likely a temporal anomaly but that
wasn't all the team began seeing flashes
of light in the distance and hearing
noises beneath them they made the
decision to pull out of the shaft and
after moving towards the light in front
of them thinking it was from the surface
they found that they were no closer to
leaving than they had been when they
entered the clock still displayed a time
of 17 minutes and trying to figure out
where they were on the shaft was
becoming next to impossible as it
couldn't get any worse the team's
flashlights and headlamps began dying
out now the task force was completely in
the dark and they could only move
downwards they weren't sure where they
were going but they were certain it was
going down the sensations of the cavern
were growing stronger strange smells
something unclear written on the walls
of the cave the clock now displayed 13
minutes the operatives began repeating
themselves stating the phrase too long
in the fire over and over again it was a
nightmare but the team soldiered onward
days by the shaft's anomalous effects
just when they were able to see the
surface light again they noticed
something there were more members of the
team than they originally started with
three of them mimicking the others
voices wearing their uniforms one of the
entities appeared as if it were on fire
smoke smoldering from its back repeating
that phrase over and over again the
captain ordered his men to shoot at the
imposters firing at them in the dark the
shots missed and accidentally hit
something that caused a violent
combustion causing all recording devices
to cut out and the foundation to remove
the task force from the shaft entirely
all four members were recovered and
given a medical evaluation the entities
that impersonated and attacked the task
force however were unable to be found
during an interview with one of the
recovered operatives he claimed that the
team was losing track of time but was
shocked to discover that while the
recorders were active for a total of 5
hours and 33 minutes they only spent 19
minutes total in the mine altogether a
strange anomalous time dilation effect
between the surface and the underground
the operative was unable to determine
the point when the entities clad in
their armor and badges joined up with a
group the interviewing doctor offered
the operative an amnestic but he
declined stating that he'll only need it
if he's still dreaming about the entity
screaming at him with his own voice
months later while the foundation's
exploration of
scp-2951 revealed the anomalous effects
of the shaft the historical
investigation also bore fruit they
learned the story of the 1944 collapse
that caused bg hoadley to sell the mine
but they also learned another important
piece of information about the lemon
quarry the foundation recovered a
contact list in an abandoned hoadley
office that allowed the foundation to
make contact with gorman ellis a retired
hoadley investigator who was cooperative
and willing to meet with the foundation
agents knocking on his door during the
interview the foundation learned that
ellis was originally a foreman with a
company and both his father and his
grandfather were associated with the
higher-ups at hoadley when asked about
the lemon quarry ellis said that while
he never worked there he did spend time
there cleaning it up after the company
had shut the mind down ellis recognized
how strange an earthquake in the area
was but couldn't put his finger on
anything strange about the collapse he
knew they lost a few men during it but
the incident wasn't talked about much he
told the agent to attempt to get a hold
of a man by the last name of barnes who
was also involved in the cleanup and had
contacts with the company who bought out
the land after hodley sold it just when
the agent was about to leave however
ellis remembered another piece of
information the cleanup that he had
worked on had over three dozen men
working at the same time but ellis said
that it was the quietest job he had ever
worked in fact he wasn't sure if a
single one of them said anything to him
the entire time he was there the
foundation received a number of personal
documents from ellis's contact barns in
the form of letters that detailed the
lemon quarry sale to kerver
international the incident was described
as a typical cave-in but also detailed
that strange men in suits appeared at
the scene weeks after asking questions
and attempting to listen to the rocks
according to the letter after this
kerver international a mining group that
the foundation has so little information
on that they believe it is anomalous
itself purchased the lemon quarry a
letter addressed to barnes reads as
follows i saw it myself jeremiah i saw
something that was like a man crawl out
of that hole smoked and burned and cried
out in another's voice it was a thing
pulled straight from the pit itself i
have no doubt a man from guy said as
much himself that the pillars that
support the world will crack and crumble
and the foundation will become loose
what lies below will become accessible
and its might will fall upon the meek i
saw it with my own eyes i know it is
true i still hear its words jeremiah 10
000 years screaming like a wild dog
shrieking like it was cornered 10 000
years in the fire in 2003 ellis passed
away with the foundation seizing his
assets during this process the
foundation discovered a letter addressed
to an unknown recipient revealing that
he knew more about the lemon quarry than
he had let on its contents are chilling
reading it was 23 in total 23 of those
poor boys got stuck behind that wall we
could hear them for days shouting behind
those rocks while we sat around and did
nothing have you ever been down in a
mine during a blackout let me tell you
about it first there is a moment of
panic when everybody scrambles to figure
out what's going on then as things calm
down you try to get your eyes adjusted
to the dark around you but you never get
adjusted because there's nothing to see
it's not like dark at night where you
can see stars on the moon or a street
light there's no light in a mine during
a blackout there's nothing to see down
there then you start to hear things some
boys will hear voices or animals or any
number of things that just aren't there
some will wander off and get lost they
won't follow the ropes back up some will
fall into a shaft or into a crevice and
you'll never see them again then it gets
real quiet i got to see that tunnel they
found before the cave-in very strange
didn't look dug up by tools not proper
didn't even have time to string up
lights in it to see where it went i
don't know what's down there anyway all
i'm saying is i haven't thought much
about hell but i sure think we deserve
it whatever happens to those boys as
long as they're down there is our fault
it's our fault for doing nothing and the
dark changes people now go watch
scp-1179 centralian fire demon and
scp-2935
oh death for more possible mine and cave
dwelling anomalies from scp explained